bullying can have a long lasting impact
on kids studies show more than one out
of every five students reports being
bullied Carice Rogers endured years of
it because of the color of her skin but
the Los Angeles eleven year old found
support and empowerment from her big
sister Jamie yuccas shows us how they
turn their bully takedown into a
successful business
you ready to get to work yeah are you
ready to get to work
don't let the garage fool you this is
the headquarters of a booming fashion
business run by sisters Karras Rogers
and Taylor Pollard they created a
t-shirt startup to prove what you wear
can change how you feel so how many
orders are we up to now a lot over
10,000 that's amazing you know for an
11-year old
and it's only been about a year 10,000
yeah yeah well now it's probably more
the sisters are now getting about a
hundred orders per day but flexing my
complexion was the result of Karis being
relentlessly bullied for her skin color
so flexing my complexion means to me
that it doesn't matter what other people
think about you it's what you think
about yourself and you don't let anybody
tell you different the bullying began
back when Karis was in first grade kids
called her a dead Roach and asked if
she'd been in the oven too long one day
her teacher asked the class to create
self-portraits then handed Karis a black
crayon
the other african-american students were
given brown and it hurt your feelings
yeah you really did because I didn't
think I was that dark but I was like a
regular like brown her mom moved her to
a more diverse school but her darker
complexion continued to isolate her
carrots would you come home and cry at
the time I wouldn't even want to go to
school she was punched and threatened so
one day she was taken aback and that's
when she expressed to me that you know
she wanted to stay in the bathtub longer
in hopes that her skin will get lighter
Taylor decided to act she posted this
picture on Twitter writing my sister is
only ten
but already royalty adding the hashtag
flexin in her complexion a saying their
grandmother used to let the girls know
they were beautiful so when you put it
out on social media did you expect like
a couple likes yeah basically cuz that's
what happens on any other picture host
yeah it's the same thing the next day
she said oh my god you're by wrong what
I'm almost like what's viral yeah how
many likes retweets what are we talking
about it was up to almost half a million
just likes and she had even more
retweets on Twitter
I broke the internet Taylor suggested
they put their slogan on shirts and sell
them online then my mom call me she was
like
Lupita is wearing your shirt I was
shocked
from an Oscar winner to Grammy Award
winning artist Alicia Keys even rapper
Snoop Dogg posted about Rogers on
Instagram whoa that's crazy food dog is
in pink
last September Karis became the youngest
designer ever to participate in New
York's Harlem Fashion Week these are the
hater blockers when the young CEO isn't
struggling to keep up with the demand
for her fashion line she tries doing
normal 11 year old kid stuff like going
to camp
so when you look in the mirror what do
you see I see black beauty
I see melanin papi I see anything you
could think of she's making up new
t-shirt names now this sisters are
certainly appreciative of the financial
reward but for them success isn't in the
money it's in the message and it's
changed like how other people feel about
their sales but I like to do making sure
other people are happy because being
comfortable with who you are
proves beauty is only skin-deep for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles Wow
I mean write that name down caress
Rodgers that is not the last time you
will hear from that channel 100 sure
great very great story yes